allawis luca meine damen und herren ihr
seht es bereits im titel eingeblendet
ich habe mir dieses gerät bestellt
wahrscheinlich wüsste gar nicht genau
was das ist dieser gegenstand nennt sich
tobi trecker und es ist eine kleine
leiste die man über usb an seinen
rechner anschließen dann klemmt man
diese leiste unter seinen monitoren
dieses gerät filmt
wo man hinschaut hört sich hart creepy
an auf jeden fall seht ihr jetzt schon
mal einen kanal eingeblendet und sobald
ich meine augen auf meinen kanal bewege
seht ihr ganz genau wo ich gerade
hinschauen können aber so ein kleiner
jack dabei machen und zwar sage ich
schaue jetzt auf den smiley
ich schaue jetzt auf luca ich schaue
jetzt auf kanäle und ich schaue jetzt
auf das gesicht dort vorne also das
funktioniert wirklich so sieht das ganze
hier für mich gerade aus und zwar
revisionen die leiste auch halo as
création ist diese leiste und die hat
einerseits auf der linken seite hier so
eine kleine lampe und auf der rechten
seite hat die auch noch mal so eine
kleine lampe und damit schaut sie quasi
wo die beiden augen hinschauen und ich
hab das auch ganz professionell mit
tesafilm befestigt also so schaue ich
mir auf jeden fall gerade meinen kanal
an das heißt wenn ich jetzt noch
beispielsweise mal komplett wegschauen
ist es weg jetzt dahin und bin wieder da
und dann bin ich wieder da so wird das
ding ist allerdings dass dieses gerät
natürlich die augen nicht perfekte eins
zu eins erfassen kann weil bei mir
natürlich auch ein mikro davon wenn ich
jetzt beispielsweise sage ich schaue auf
kanäle
ich schaue punktgenau auf kanäle dann
seht ihr schon dass das ganze ein
bisschen weiter oben das ganze ab film
beziehungsweise das gerät denken dass
ich ein bisschen über kanäle gerade
genau hinschaue das ist aber nicht
weiter schlimm da die richtung ja auf
jeden fall passt wir geben jetzt einfach
mal einen hier oben in der suche katja
krawitz fachleuten als meine reaction
[Musik]
jetzt seht ihr auch wohin schauen das
ist echt krass eigentlich man kann halt
locker auch spiele damit machen dann
muss man irgendwo hinschauen und das
steht was ich meine auf jeden fall
machen wir heute zusammen auch diesen
standard test den beispielsweise auch
schon peinlich sondern ähnlichen formen
gemacht hat oder auch simon ungefähr ein
paar tagen und zwar schauen uns ein
video von katja an und ich darf nicht
auf dinge schauen die hat ja so an sich
hat ich möchte da ganz gerne eigentlich
mal ein video von ihrem kanal nehmen was
werbe freundlich ist damit mein video
hier auch werbe freundlich ist die sache
ist nur valentinstags strip da weiß man
schon was abgeht wir nehmen einfach mal
krasser mädelsabend mit micaela schäfer
ein paar sekunden später melde dich an
dein alter zu bestätigen ja okay dann
nehmen wir das doch nicht ich habe mich
jetzt für das video entschieden omg
valentinstag strip katja krasa wird da
dachte ich mir zwar eigentlich aus dass
es ab 18 ist allerdings hat das keine
altersbeschränkung von daher kann meine
reaktion ja auch keine
altersbeschränkung bekommen das jetzt
auf jeden fall die kanal und ich hab
gerade schon das erste mal auf ihre
oberweite geschaut hat ja erklärt uns
heute anscheinend wie man am
valentinstag einen tanz für seinen
partner machen kann wie gesagt ich darf
nicht auf oder
los geht's ich merke ich mir meine augen
wird es runter geht und dann sehe ich
das programm check direkt beschenken
kann was ich immer schenkel ist halt
irgendwas war sex bedeutet halt so
erzählt ja was kann man denn jemand zum
valentinstag schenken ja also ich würde
sagen rosen und vielleicht ein kino
haben irgendwas was mit sex zu tun hat
dass immer das was ich schenke also auf
jeden fall schon mal grob sein katja für
das beste weibchen geschenk überhaupt
die sache ist allerdings ich bin ganz
ehrlich man muss sich ja nicht dafür
schämen
ich meine ich bin heterosexuell
natürlich schaue ich da hin
aber ich glaube auch dass mädels bei
jungs wenn das die dann oder ich weiß
nicht sind mädels schauen also
ich hätte mir immer gerne in die
kommentare schreiben ich finde es auf
jeden fall nicht verwerflich aber hier
ich habe schon wieder hingeschaut wir
schauen einfach mal weiter
und das muss man ihr wirklich lassen ich
werde mal ab jetzt einen counter hier
oben einfügen
wie oft ich bisher schon da hingeschaut
habe und der zählt dann mal weiter
reicht hier auf youtube in und natürlich
dazu
und dann zeige ich euch
das ist unfair da waren meine augen doch
vor dem gesicht das ist das gerade war
unter das war nichts würde ich sagen
dass ich hatte ja da kann ich jetzt muss
ich jetzt kurzweg gucken weil man hier
geschichtlich gesehen hat okay jetzt bin
ich wieder auf ihrem gesicht hat er ein
darth vader maske auf jedes geschenk
beziehungsweise ich jetzt stellt euch
auf den tischen börsen zu hause nicht
offen und der mann setzt sich auf die
couch muss auf jeden fall von unten nach
oben schauen
alles sieht was man so hört man kann
verschiedene bewegungen machen einfach
was sexy aus magath macht die sache ist
man muss ja dahin schauen sie zeigt ihr
auch dahin sie guckt ja auch selbst
dahin das ist ja echt schwierig die
sache ist dass mir das ganze natürlich
auch noch mit dem kompletten gegenteil
machen kann und zwar könnte man ja auch
ein video nehmen wo man nicht wegschauen
darf also beispielsweise bei krassen
fußball fouls oder unfällen oder
ekelhaften tieren als die sonne don't
look away challenge von mir mal sehen
wollt dann stellen wir gern und die
kommentare und bei 50.000 kommen nächste
woche
man habe ich echt angst vor also ja wenn
ihr das wollt der lasten daumen hoch da
und wir schauen uns jetzt weiter katjas
tutorial katja fängt jetzt hier an
einer war einfach audio channel drin
falls sie nicht wissen was das heißt
audio jungle ist so eine plattform wo
man hintergrundmusik sich holen kann für
videos et cetera und wenn man sich die
nicht kauft dann kommt er mit akkordeon
jungle sound und katja wohl zu geizig
sich diesen song zu kaufen
es geht ja nicht anders man ich glaube
alle jungs die gerade zuschauer
verstehen mich ja muss jetzt ist er ihre
hand würde ich jetzt mal ganz kurz was
macht sie denn überhaupt für content wie
kann denn so ein video auch 18.000 likes
überhaupt erst mal bekommen also nichts
gegen katja persönlich ich habe sie noch
nie kennen gelernt aber ich würde sowas
nicht hochladen glaubt sowas wird auch
keiner von mir sehen
wenn er einen geilen abstaubte mich ja
darauf an hast kann ich jetzt natürlich
da wenn der kameramann nur auf ihren
arsch will dann kann ich natürlich nicht
irgendwo anders hin schauen sie sind das
für ein tutorial und dann wie man darf
natürlich anpassen
ja ich weiß jetzt mit dem kutter das ist
wahrscheinlich schwierig jetzt weiß ich
auch gerne mache das können sie auch
machen ist zu champagner nehmen und über
euren körper schützen oder das was er
gerne trinken sind ja abschließt auf
trinkt einen kaffee sorgen über euren
körper und einfach und da ganz kurz
also wenn ich mir das jetzt richtig
vorstellen meine liebe katja dann machst
du sehr gerne dass du rumtanzt und dann
getränke weil ich darüber gibt ja mache
ich auch immer und da wenn ihr merkt
dass der bock hat sich ihr euch komplett
aus auf den tanga und den gefahren
also ich meine ich würde das video jetzt
auch nicht ab 18 machen aber man merkt
schon die richtung die sich langsam von
youtube entfernt
das ist megageil sahne was in ihr könnt
das gewinnen nicht jeder kriegt das ist
mir einfach auf instagram und instagram
da hab ich jetzt auf jeden fall
angeschaut
ich habe das video hat euch gefallen
konnte ich von weinberg das klingt schön
ok
also ich meine ich nicht mehr
auch auf aber ich bin gespannt was da
für eine zahl steht
59 in einem vier minuten video habe ich
noch 50 mal 80 angestellte sich das
heutige video ist allerdings auch
beenden meine lieben freunde wenn euch
dieses video hier gefallen hat dann
würde ich mich sehr wertvoll bei einen
daumen hoch freuen wie bereits gesagt
wenn ihr wollte sich das ganze noch mal
mit einer don't look way challenge
machen soll also nicht wegschauen dann
schreib mir das gerne und in die
kommentare schreibt mir auch gerne
weitere ideen die man eventuell mit
diesem treffer machen könnte auch unten
in die kommentare weil ich glaube die
möglichkeiten damit sind grenzenlos
wieder andere youtuber haben mit diesem
alter auch bereits videos hochgeladen
allen voran natürlich juli bei der das
ganze von einem jahr gemacht hat und in
letzter zeit hat das unglück auch so ein
bisschen nach deutschland rüber gebracht
also schaut euch auch auf jeden fall die
videos von denen an die sind auch sehr
sehr sehr sehr lustig geworden
wie bereits gesagt ich habe nichts gegen
katja persönlich und nur weil ich jetzt
sage das ist irgendwie da habe ich ein
bisschen komisch ich finde halt ihre
videos echt ein bisschen komisch oder
ansonsten möchte sie jetzt auch beenden
[Musik]